cyber security Awareness Month the
latest for IBM storage and IBM AI
governance all on this episode of IBM
Tech now
what's up y'all my name is Ian and I am
back to bring you the latest and
greatest news and announcements about
IBM technology
October is National cyber security
awareness month and we're celebrating
incident responders across the industry
we want to recognize and appreciate our
cyber Frontline responders for their
heroic efforts in defending
organizations clients and the world from
cyber attacks
modern day cyber attacks have evolved
past solely impacting Data Systems in
I.T environments they now impact our
access to essential Services goods and
the economy hospitals food manufacturers
and schools are among the victims we've
seen brought to Temporary standstills by
ransomware gangs over recent years
this means that incident responders
today are charged with much more than
defending against Data Theft they're
tasked with ensuring the world continues
to run and it's a sense of service that
drives the IR Community to do what they
do so we salute them for it in the
sacrifice that follows so I hope you all
will join me in recognizing our unsung
cyber security Heroes and celebrating
them throughout the month
we've even created a microsite where you
can create and customize your own
appreciation post and post it on your
social networks to learn more and spread
the Gratitude see the links I've got in
the description of this video
next up let's take a look at how IBM is
redefining hybrid Cloud application and
data storage we're thrilled to announce
that red hat is transferring its storage
portfolio and Associated teams including
Red Hat stuff storage Red Hat openshift
data Foundation rook and nuba to IBM
storage so what does that mean well we
believe this creates the most complete
and Powerful software-defined storage
portfolio in the industry
working together with red hat we're
accelerating our Innovation and
leveraging open source to deliver an
industry-leading portfolio and a
consistent experience for our clients
across on-premises infrastructure and
Cloud
the result Hardware agnostic storage
services that truly redefine hybrid
cloud storage for applications and data
across bare metal virtualized and
containerized environments this means
faster hybrid multi-cloud deployments
with greater Simplicity and expanded
platform support backed by IBM's Global
sales and life cycle services
to learn more about this exciting news
check out the blog link below
to finish things up let's talk a little
about AI governance
AI governance is an overarching legal
framework that uses a set of automated
processes methodologies and tools to
manage an organization's use of AI
consistent principles that guide the
design development deployment and
monitoring models are critical to
driving trustworthy AI
at IBM we believe that it is the
responsibility of every organization to
adhere to ethical explainable AI
respecting individual rights privacy and
non-discrimination
that's why we're proud to introduce IBM
AI governance a new One-Stop solution
that is designed to help businesses meet
their regulatory requirements and
address ethical concerns through
software automation
everything needed to develop a
consistent transparent model management
process is included in IBM AI governance
and it is built on three critical
principles lifecycle governance risk
management and Regulatory Compliance
to learn more about how IBM is driving
trustworthy Ai and register for the AI
governance webinar hit the link below
thanks so much for joining me today for
this episode of IBM Tech now if you're
interested in learning more about the
topics I've covered make sure you
explore the links in the description
this video and again please don't forget
to subscribe to our channel to stay up
to date on what's going on in Tech now